e aí galera que a gente meus vídeos bom
vocês lembrando que quem ainda não está
inscrito meu canal que clicar aqui
inscrever se para tudo estiver de novo
você sabe quanto tempo a galera o que
vocês queriam dividir novo vocês falaram
que iriam ditas eu pedi que vocês
fizessem perguntas para poder responder
isso reúne as melhores e que vai
responder agora avaliações no twitter
perguntou windows o que os homens acham
das mulheres se um livre a gente gosta
ou moto do [ __ ] quem não gosta de
saber que você é importante para o texto
nicole pai perguntou o erro supor que os
homens acham que sabe de tudo porque a
gente sabe tudo por brincadeira porque a
gente aguenta acha que sabe tudo não
sabe nada do twitter fases do unicef meu
pai um tom wilson porque quando o homem
se trata uma mulher bem demais dizem que
ele é gay porque são burros porque o
cara que está tratando a mulher bem está
sendo chamado de guetta pelo
relacionamento dez vezes melhor do que o
do carro que chama de gay e que não
trata a mulher bem
marcelo tubino marcelo lima perguntou o
isso porque as mulheres ficam com aquela
vozinha quando querem de alguma coisa
pra gente
admiro muito seus vídeos valeu marcelo
lima é porque aquela vozinha tem poder
se a falar no canto música pra mim aí
fala né a ela fala um favorzinho tamanho
canto no facebook ramon barcelos
perguntou por que as mulheres dizem que
todos os homens são iguais
a mais simples quando a mulher fala que
todos os homens são iguais é porque ela
já provou muitos homens porque pra saber
que todos são iguais com que provado na
verdade que os homens não são iguais
vocês que estão escolhendo errado
o dn silveira perguntou como elas
conseguem ser tão chatos e nós
continuamos amando elas porque a gente é
gol lucas rodrigues pinto porque ela
sempre quer matar nossos amigos porque
elas se sentem ameaçados pelas nossas
amendoim por sami ricardo perguntou por
que o amigo não pode ser um futuro
namorado
esse que vai ser pelo outro vídeo o
hélder sousa perguntei por que as
mulheres não consegue ficar enrolando os
homens quando os dois ele ela querem
porque as mulheres gostam de ficar
enrolando os homens quando os dois ele
elas por que as mulheres gostam de ficar
ela querem mas fica fazendo jogo duro
porque é bom cara mas nem se torna
eficaz para quem fala assim é eu tô afim
de você tá bom melhor de uma nova casa
tem que ter um jogo não vai ter graça
o vinícius gonçalves perguntou porque no
chão de safado quando falam de sexo
considerando o fato que elas querem nos
dar tanto quanto nós ganhamos com les
mines na verdade é que o papel da mulher
na sociedade é se manter resgatada
porque chamado de safado é a que ele
chama de amor e as que dão fácil a gente
chama de [ __ ] o ranking ela perguntou
você sabe tudo sobre elas
sei porque eu sou [ __ ] brincadeira não
não sei mas acho que um pouco que o
senhor possa ajudar o sábio ao
experimentou as mulheres procuram os
homens pela aparência pelo caráter sabe
a verdade é que isso é conversa de gente
feia porque quando a gente efe a gente
joga a culpa no bonito no rio num
bombardeio
sempre que a gente tem que fazer é
esquecer essa [ __ ] pra cima se você for
bonito não tiver um bom caráter mas ele
por onde você tiver caráter for feio é
de ver seu procurar um salão de beleza
a tal ong o twitter perguntou por que a
maioria dos homens no mundo em ajudas e
como é a mulher ideal para o garoto se
apaixonar de verdade não é a maioria dos
homens que não têm vocês já que você
disponha as pessoas erradas ea mulher
ideal é só você se você mesmo quem disse
que você está conhecendo a menina ea
menina se mostra a pessoa mais
maravilhosa da terra e aí quando se
namora com ela não é nada a ver com
aquilo que eu tinha mostrado que eu seja
você mesmo que eu acho que dá certo
eu acho a nati santana perguntou eu não
sei por que os homens trocam mais mulher
do que de cueca porque nosso foco é
confortável apesar da maioria dos meus
amigos e do sexo feminino foi o primeiro
muito com elas e aprender um pouco sobre
a vida de vocês não consigo responder
todas as perguntas que afinal não sou
mulher eu acho é isso não então convidar
uma pessoa legal para poder responder às
perguntas pra vocês também vai lá e aí
galera beleza meu nome é tarsila do eu
também sou blogueiro se vocês quiserem
acompanhar meus vídeos se espera um lado
do canal youtube.com barra da silva rio
a primeira pergunta foi do jardim são
luiz e ele perguntou assim o que vocês
dizem não quando querem dizer
acho que é só você mesmo pode responder
ou se imaginar que você está na balada e
tem duas meninas rua
se você falar praticamente o lance mão
de vocês já lhe agarrou ea outra está
marca lá no cantinho dela sem falar nada
com quem a senhora prefere ficar com
aquela que se jogou em cima de você nos
seus braços a qualquer que estava mais
quietinha na dela e provavelmente tem a
questão que quando alguém diz não é
porque realmente é não então vocês
precisam assim entender como o não é não
e quando o que não é assim a segunda
pergunta foi gabriel vieira ele
perguntou se por que insistem tanto em
um homem quando ele não quer eu acho que
as meninas são burras idiotas etapas
assim ao extremo porque sabia que o
homem lá o menino sei lá o que seja não
quer ela porque não fico assistindo a
terceira pergunta foi domingo o haiti
ele perguntou por que se umas bestas
ciúmes até de regatas o carro regatas é
camisa regata né
eu acho que assim se uma coisa assim uma
coisa vez que se você gosta de alguma
coisa
até vou dizer sim um exemplo também de
descer lá alguma coisa que você tem você
influenciamos a todo aquele seu espelho
os filmes daquela sua sandália e não
deixe ninguém cá e é a mesma coisa mas é
uma prova de cuidado uma prova que você
gosta daquela coisa ou daquela pessoa
mas aí eles filmes de com meninos usando
regatos acho que não gerou um pouquinho
essa menina é possível assim só a outra
pergunta foi de gabriel beck eu espero
que tenha acertado seu nome se não
aceitei disco e ele perguntou assim
porque as mulheres quando tomadas falam
que estão gordas e quando estão gordas
falam que tomar bom esse caso aí não é o
meu eu sou muito magra eu me vejo na
área que é um engodo assim próximo a um
espelho do gol de queria eu sei isso aí
mas a questão também é
e as mulheres geralmente não gostam
muito do seu corpo é uma guerra se o
homem também é por isso que vou pra casa
e e gosta de ficar fora isso todo mundo
é assim todo mundo não gosto de alguma
coisa principal essa questão não só as
mulheres só que não gostem disse e
desenhar do borda alho tomate
não é só a mulher ea última pergunta
quem perguntou foi o danilo nogueira eu
espero que tenha aceitado seu nome
se você também me desculpe a pergunta
foi porque só vão ao banheiro com uma
amiga na verdade assim é porque contar
com uma dupla assim de amiga ou várias
isso é um código assim porque como
sempre no banheiro e vai se
transformando o salão de beleza e aí
aparece profissional dito que ela a
floresta do chão escova maquiagem não
todo o ano todo o ano a verdade é que as
meninas sempre vão acompanhadas de um
banheiro na questão de retocar a
maquiagem tirar foto pelo menos eu como
banheiro quebrou com a amiga
a gente sempre fica um espelho falando
alguma coisa que você sabe sobre o que
acontecer você silicone naquela roupa
aquela menina lá eu não gostei você
pessoal só para tirar foto mesmo eu
adoro de aforro entorse que foi o vídeo
de hoje muito obrigado se você não está
inscrito no canal e quer saber quando
tem vídeo novo é só clicar em inscrever
se você gostou do vídeo secitec em
alguma coisa por favor clique aqui
gostei que isso ajuda muito quando vejo
que tem muito gostei que ela fica um que
sempre vale quer fazer mais e comenta
aqui embaixo que você acha mais estranho
um homem o que você acha mais estranha
mulher se inscreve também no canadá
china e ezequiel escreve aí e muito
obrigada nos próximos vídeos só vou
fazer as perguntas no twitter
então me segue no twitter e valeu